- Hello.
What's your name?
What's my name?
Hello.
(mellow music)
- It's a team effort, like
it's genuinely a team effort.
- Come, come.
See for yourself.
(mellow music)
- Wonderful.
- She hits him so first.
(clangs)
She told you to let go.
- Go?
Leave?
No, no, no.
Still much to do, plan not yet done.
Chamberlain will decide when
Gruenak service is finished.
- Excuse me.
Thank you, if I could just, excuse me.
(carriage crashes)
(adventurous music)
- We are eternal.
- So our standard height here,
we have four foot high rostrums.
There's the finished set floor
and then the set sits on top.
And that's so we can open up the floor
to drop the puppeteers in to have
the creatures at the right height.
- I've never seen such a creature before.
Good day.
(growls)
(yells)
- Woo.
- Ya, ya.
(squeals)
(barks)
(crunches)
- My name's Deet, I'm a Gelfling.
- How very interesting.
- It's not about size.
It's about vigor.
(adventurous music)
- Oh Sanctuary Tree,
we have not spoken in a long time.
- There's something wonderful about
knowing you can pause any frame
and that no moment in
there is an accident.
Every leaf you see has been placed there.
Every movement of the
character has been considered.
(creatures clicking)
(creature snarls)
- Now go.
You heroes of Thra.
Go and save our world.
(adventurous music)
- [Man] Tell no one.